scp-035 vs scp-096  the possessive mask versus the shy guy  two forces of terrifying malice and  destruction but who would win  scp-096 enters a rage state when anyone  sees its face being both indestructible  and unstoppable under these conditions  however the real question is whether  scp-035 really sees meaning it may not  activate 096's aggression at all  scp-035 is a dangerous mind-controlling  mask with evil intentions that slowly  melts its hosts however we would argue  that these two might be a match made in  hell  scp-096 may love having its face covered  by a mask and 0-3-5 would love having an  indestructible body if we put these two  up against each other we'd be the ones  in trouble